when Barack Obama was inaugurated in
2009 the oath of office was administered
by supreme court Chief Justice John
Roberts who was known for being a
stickler for correct grammar so much so
that he decided to change the wording of
the oath from I solemnly swear that I
will Faithfully execute the office of
President of the United States to that I
will execute the office of president to
the United States faithfully and I will
execute
the grammar crime that Roberts believed
the founding fathers had committed was
splitting a verb phrase will execute
with an adverb Faithfully
[Music]
this is similar to the popular rule
against not splitting infinitives like
to eat to run or to think which means
Captain Kirk should have said to go
boldly where no man has gone before
doesn't quite have the same ring does it
turns out that just unilaterally
deciding to change the wording of the
Constitution isn't a good idea some
legal Scholars worried that if the oath
wasn't recited verbatim Obama might not
actually be president just to be safe
the two men repeated the ceremony later
as written this is an extreme example of
how being a grammar cop can get you into
trouble but besides the social and
cultural downsides of trying to police
how others talk there's some persuasive
arguments that many of the grammatical
errors that are frequently called out
might not be errors at all I'm Dr Erica
brazowski and it's time to boldly break
some grammar rules on other words
[Music]
other words
have you ever corrected someone's
grammar and gotten the response wow
thank you so much for pointing out my
foolish mistake please let me know if I
make any others in the future
yeah not likely being told that you
speak wrong is uniquely insulting
because it's so tied to perceptions of
class education and intelligence the
wealthy and educated have good grammar
and the poor and uneducated have bad
grammar believing in good grammar is
inherently prescriptive it's concerned
with how things ought to be but
Linguistics like most Sciences is
descriptive it tries to describe the way
things actually are
just as it would be ludicrous for a
biologist to say that a species of bird
doesn't fly the way it ought to it's
equally nonsensical for a linguist to
say that certain groups of people don't
talk the way they should instead of
correct speech versus incorrect speech
what linguists observe in the real world
is a bunch of different dialects with
different sets of rules these rules can
shift or change but they're always
internally consistent if a group of
teenagers for example were just speaking
a degraded or sloppy form of English
then it should be easy for an adult to
imitate of course we know it isn't their
dialect has rules and they know
instantly when they're broken perhaps
the most denigrated of dialects is
African-American English or black
English many features of the dialect
like negative Concord and zero copula
are common grammatical practices across
many languages yet some continue to use
them as examples of bad grammar
throughout much of the 20th century many
educational psychologists thought that
low income black kids spoke a stunted or
inferior version of English and some
believe that they had virtually no
language at all then in the late 60s a
linguistic study of children in Harlem
found that the grammar they used was in
fact rich and consistent capable of just
as much nuance and precision as any
other English dialect this was an
important step in academics
acknowledging that the
disproportionately poor school
performance of black children was due in
part to the fact that unlike their white
middle-class counterparts they are being
asked to learn in a different dialect
than the one they were raised in the
study also found that when compared with
upper middle class speakers of so-called
Standard English speakers of AAE tended
to commit fewer grammatical mistakes
mismatches and redundancies why possibly
because what we call Standard English
doesn't come very naturally it contains
a lot of arbitrary rules made up
hundreds of years ago which most of us
have had to learn by force in school
rather than naturally with friends and
family take Captain Kirk's supposed
mistake the split infinitive the
foundation for this rule dates back to
the 19th century suggestion by The
Scholar Henry Alford the safest choice
is to avoid splitting infinitives
somehow this morphed into a hard rule by
the middle of the 20th century with some
arguing that since Latin never splits
infinitives neither should English but
you can't split Latin infinitives
because they're always just one word
like Amare English infinitives are two
words and there's no good reason why you
can't split them another supposed rule
based on Latin conventions is not ending
a sentence with a preposition like that
Infamous hack Shakespeare did when he
wrote We are such stuff as dreams are
made on
again in Latin prepositions can't be
separated
but that's no reason why we can't do it
in English and would anyone really say
to whom do you think you're talking
instead of who do you think you're
talking to
speaking of whom it is technically the
objective case for the nominative who
but over the last century it's largely
fallen out of usage and that's hardly
unheard of plenty of other pronouns use
one word for subject and object like it
that's what and where until relatively
recently there were four second-person
pronouns that all collapsed into you it
seems pretty clear that whom will
someday be as archaic as the and thou
okay so what about that most offensive
of grammatical transgressions me and
Jennifer are going swimming we can all
agree that's wrong right after all you
wouldn't say me is going swimming
believe it or not some linguists even
think this construction isn't so bad the
head of a clause is the key word that
determines its nature so in this noun
phrase the head is man and the verb must
agree with it the man is going swimming
but conjunctive phrases those with
multiple nouns are are considered
headless there is no one word that
determines case neither noun on its own
matches the verb are the individual
parts are not required to perfectly
agree with the verb
which of these two sentences are you
more likely to say everyone but her won
an award or everyone but she won an
award even though the second is
technically correct the vast majority of
English speakers find it clunky and
unnatural why is that linguist Joseph
Emmons argues that English speakers have
a natural inclination to use the
objective pronoun case in conjunctive
clauses
this is perhaps because we mentally
reserve the nominative case for subject
heads only just doesn't feel right to
say he or she or they unless it refers
to the sole subject of a sentence this
is a perfectly consistent and reasonable
grammatical rule yet we've had it beaten
out of us in favor of one that is no
more logical and a lot less natural if
this isn't enough for you I am even
going to defend the figurative use of
the word literally as in I am literally
starving to death
be called an ironic intensifier like
saying oh I could definitely use another
problem today
and the usage isn't even new in Nicholas
Nickleby Charles Dickens wrote his looks
were very Haggard and his Limbs and body
literally worn to the Bone at this point
some of you may be literally gasping for
breath these grammatical heresies so
let's say a few things in offensive
so-called Standard English first of all
it has allowed English grammar to say
remarkably unchanged for hundreds of
years that's why Jane Austen sounds more
or less modern to our ears yet
Shakespeare would have sounded archaic
to her even though the two time spans
are roughly equivalent it's also useful
in expressing formality if you're going
to speak at a funeral or go on a job
interview using standard English as a
social cue that you take the occasion
seriously and like it or not Standard
English is still associated with
proficiency and education many career
Fields require that you be able to speak
and write it if you want to get far
being proficient in standard English is
a valuable asset but it's not necessary
for everyone or every occasion expecting
people to use a formal dialect than
casual situations like a party or
comment section is ludicrous and if the
point of language is to facilitate
understanding and form social bonds it's
almost always counterproductive to
correct someone's grammar if they're not
asking for it and maybe that's the main
argument for not being a grammar cop no
one likes it literally no one
history lovers we need to tell you about
a new series from PBS called the bigger
picture hosted by Professor Vincent
Brown it's a show that examines famous
photographs and unpacks the historical
context around them in doing so we
reveal what these photos can tell us
about our history but also how we view
ourselves check the link in the
description and head to the PBS YouTube
channel to see it for yourself tell them
other words sent you
some legal Scholars worried that if the
oath wasn't oath oaf I said oh
but that's not no that's not no reason
why it's time to boldly break some of
Grandma that was all weird that was all
sorts of not it